-My first guest is
one of my favorites.
She is a Golden Globe-winning
actress
starring in a new film
called "Yes Day,"
which premieres
on Netflix tomorrow.
Here is Jennifer Garner!
Ah, come on.
Ah, the best!
-Come on, Jimmy!
-Welcome back.
-Oh!
-Thank you.
-I'm so happy to see you, buddy.
-I'm so happy
to see you, too, bud.
You recently posted a photo
with your "13 Going on 30"
costar Mark Ruffalo,
and the Internet broke in half.
They went crazy.
We have that photo.
You guys just --
-Aw.
-You guys just wrapped
another movie together
called "The Adam Project."
What was it like working
together again?
-It was so instantly comfortable
and there was just
so much trust there.
There's just nothing like having
known people for a long time.
You know, there's nothing
like -- it made you feel
more brave and it made you
feel really safe.
It was lovely.
I just loved being
with Mark again.
-And also, Ryan Reynolds
is in the movie.
Let me just say, if I could sit
at a table with you,
Mark Ruffalo, and Ryan Reynolds,
that's the best table.
I mean, you're three of
the most talented people,
but also funny,
but also giving and caring.
What was Ryan like?
-Well, first of all --
Well, there's also Zoe Saldana
and Catherine Keener,
so it's just an amazing --
it's such a cool cast
to be a part of.
-Oh, my gosh.
-But it is going to be
such a special movie.
I cannot wait
for you guys to see it.
We're all used to
laughing at Ryan,
but just have
a box of tissues ready
'cause he's gonna tear your
heart out and feed it to you.
-Really?
-Yeah. He's a killer.
He's my son.
You know, he's Mark and my son.
Little baby Ryan Reynolds.
-[ Laughs ]
That's perfect, man.
That is great.
I have to say, your new movie
"Yes Day" comes out
on Netflix tomorrow.
This is really your baby.
Not only do you star in it,
but you produced it as well.
Congrats on that.
I think it's a perfect movie
for you.
I think in my head -- and I may
be wrong -- that that is you --
I think you'd be
the best mom ever.
I think you're so fun.
-Oh, my gosh. I don't know.
I think the whole point
of "Yes Day"
is because no matter what, moms
stop being fun all the time.
We just, like, kind of
turn into a drag,
just being like,
"Do you have your socks on?
Have you brushed your teeth?
Do you have your soccer cleats
for later?"
And you just get kind of
robotic and rigid
trying to make it all happen.
So my kids, I started doing
a yes day with my kids
when, really, a long time ago
because my daughter loved
Amy Krouse Rosenthal --
beautiful angel --
her book "Yes Day" so much.
Kids books make
such a difference, Jimmy.
Just wait till I get to make
one of yours into a movie.
I'll be so excited.
-It's a two-word movie.
-Yeah, exactly.
But my daughter loved the book
so much,
she begged for a yes day,
and we did it,
and then we started doing
them as a tradition,
once a year, the kids and I
would, for nine years.
And now, here it is.
It's a movie.
And I can't wait for people to
see it because it really is fun
and joyful and after a year
of just solid no,
it's just a big, fat, juicy yes.
-[ Laughs ] Exactly.
The other thing is how many
times you actually have to say
no in the movie, and you do
it -- every one is different.
But you're like,
"No, no, nope, no."
And then, there's one you say
that's stuck in my head.
You go, "Nope on a rope.
Nope on a rope."
I just -- That one crushed me.
-Try it.
I'm offering for all of America.
Please try "nope on a rope,"
because it's no, but it's kicky.
-Yeah, it's got
a little kick to it, yeah.
"No. Nope."
-It's got a little kick.
-Nope on a rope, yeah.
-Nope on a rope.
-Was there anything doing this
movie that made you turn around
and say -- wish you said no?
You go,
"Yeah, I said yes to that.
I should have said no."
-I don't like singing
in front of people,
and I sing in
this stinking movie.
And actually, I don't think --
I don't know if I'm allowed
to say this, but I'm going to
just break a rule and tell you,
H.E.R. is in our film,
and H.E.R. plays music
in our film and has a scene.
She is incredible.
-A genius.
-She's the most unbelievable --
and her band is there as well.
And then, I had to sing with
H.E.R., the H.E.R., yes.
-No, no, no.
No, that's pressure.
-Yeah, I can't even
think about it.
I can't -- I went out --
I had to say to the audience
beforehand, I had to say like,
"I don't like to sing
in front of people.
You're all here. We have to
get through this together.
If I pee my pants, have just --
we're just going to
have a laugh.
I don't know
what's gonna happen.
We just have to
get through it together.
So God bless you."
-I thought you nailed it.
I also want to say,
we were talking earlier
and I said like,
"I wish people could see this,"
you know, in a crowd,
and you were like,
"Yeah, weirdly, we tested it
with families through TVs,"
and they let you watch them
react to the movie
so you can edit
and stuff like that?
-It was amazing!
Like, I've never tested a movie
like this,
but it's Netflix and you're
supposed to watch it at home.
There was a pandemic.
So we had cameras up on their --
we were able to watch
the families watching the movie,
and they would be
leaving the room,
grabbing popcorn, all laughing,
doing what they do.
But as the movie came to
the third act, everyone --
and I was watching 150 families
screening through Zoom screens
and watching them get
closer and closer
till they were huddled up
on the couch
and the moms,
like, wiping a tear.
And we were like,
"Yes, we did it! We did it."
It was the best.
That's all you want.
You just want, like, my goal
is for there to be families
all over the world
cuddled up on the couch
by the end of the movie.
-I want to show a clip
from the movie.
Here's Jennifer Garner
in "Yes Day."
Take a look.
-I'm sorry, but you got to
make it through a yes morning,
let alone a yes day.
-Would you like to have
a little wager on that?
-You know what? I would love to.
How about this?
If you say no one time,
I get to go to Flea Fest
with Layla.
No adults, no parents.
Just us young, underage,
vulnerable girls.
-Wait, honey, are you sure?
-I'll take your wager, missy,
because I know that
I won't say no.
And when you lose --
and you will lose --
I am so fun that you will still
get to go to your concert.
-Really?
-Absolutely.
With me!
I'm gonna sit right next to you
and we're gonna hold hands
and we're gonna put our hands in
the air like we just don't care.
-Jennifer Garner, everybody.
"Yes Day" premieres tomorrow
on Netflix.